hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
pluripotent stem cell research
fundamentals
of cultivation and differentiation i am
michelle ashton of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labruts
and brought to you by miltoni biotek to
learn more visit miltonibbiotech.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
please click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this
presentation is educational thus offers
continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker viola
stella palladino
the global product manager of
pluripotent stem cell research
at milton e biotech for a complete
biography
on our speaker please visit the
biography tab
at the top of your screen yola you may
now begin your
presentation thank you michelle for the
kind introduction so i am really pleased
to have the
opportunity to give this webinar today
so today we will focus on pluripotent
stem cell research
and we will go through some fundamentals
of cultivation
characterization and differentiation
but let's start with a quick
introduction
on stem cells so
as you may already know all stem cells
show two key characteristics on one hand
they have the capacity to self-renewing
and produce more of the same cell type
on the other hand when they are exposed
to
certain patterning factors stem cells
have the ability of differentiating into
many different specialized
cell types this last characteristic
can be better explained by the concept
of cellular potency
cell potency in fact describes the
ability of the cells
to differentiate into other cell types
and the more cell type a cell can
differentiate
into the greater is its potency
in this webinar we will focus on
solution for pluripotent stem cells
pscs that are known to be able to
differentiate into all the embryonic
derivatives
there are mainly two types of pscs
that can be distinguished according to
their
origin so we have embryonic stem cells
that are originally derived from the
inner cell mass of a developing embryo
whereas differently induced pluripotent
stem cells
ipscs are derived from already
differentiated somatic cells
by cellular reprogramming other than
this difference in in the origin
embryonic stem cells
and induced pluripotent stem cells are
actually extremely
uh similar in terms of cultivation
morphology marker expression
and also experimental handling
also in regard of the differentiation
potential they show similar properties
and they can both give rise to cells
that derive
from the three embryonic lineages so
ectoderm mesoderm and endoderm
while working with pscs there are three
main
main steps that come into play
if we aim to generate new ipsc
lines directly from donors then
the first main task is the reprogramming
independently if we work with embryonic
or
induced reporters themselves they both
need to be
cultivated for further expansion
and finally the key step in psc
research is the differentiation process
that
allows us to have a functional and
appropriate cellular model
that we can use than for our experiments
so as you may anticipate each one of
these main steps
will require further subs tasks so let's
start
by having a better look to pse culture
before going into detail let's see how
pscs
are usually cultivated so classically
pacs have been cultured in presence
of supportive feeder cells
such as for example mitotically
inactivated mouse embryonic fibroblast
that supports the growth of pscs through
the secretion
of various extracellular molecules
unfortunately with this type of culture
is not
actually really possible to quantify
and qualify the factors that are
secreted by the feeders
and therefore it's really difficult to
provide a
standardized culturing condition in
every experiment so this is the reason
why
feeder-free cultivation system has been
developed
and are now actually the predominant
cultivation system in psc research
so this type of culturing basically
replaced the
need of feeder by providing on one side
a culturing matrix where the cells can
adhere
and and lay and on the other side
by providing an optimized cultural media
that provides the cells with all the
nutrients and the factors that
would have been secreted by by the
feeder cells
so in the light of it is easy to
understand
how a feeder-free cultivation system
should
always spread affair
but what to do in case
you are still using a feeder culture
system
well there are actually uh several
methods that can be used to switch from
a feeder to a seeder-free condition
in fact as you may see here on the left
the removal of the feeder cells can be
done for example
by selective adhesion that takes
advantage
of the preferential adherence of feeders
to uncoated culture plates or
it can be done by winning of the feeder
cells
over several passages or finally it can
be done by
magnetic separation so the first two
approaches are time consuming and do not
always manage to remove all feeder cells
whereas in contrast the magnetic
isolation that targets
feeder specific markers is way
faster and simple for example
here on the right you may see the flow
analysis of
pse cultures before and after
removal of the feeder cells and
as you can see not only you can obtain a
highly pure population of pluripotent
stem cells
but also the whole procedure takes just
about
20 minutes so clearly
when we have switched to a feeder-free
cultivation system
the media that we are going to use
needs to have a more robust formulation
compared to the one we could use
in cedar core culture in
general in fact the propagation of
pluripotent stem cells requires a
special attention
and qualified regions in fact
pscs are very very sensitive cells and
of course
a robust and stable culture media is a
fundamental requisite
for a successful culture
a good medium in this case should
contain
factors that allow the maintenance of a
pre-potent phenotype
and should not contain any factor that
can restrict the cellular phage
moreover the formulation
needs to be tailored for the psc
metabolism
and requirements that are slightly
different
to the one of differentiated cells
last but not least the media needs to
have
a stable and consistent composition
every time
so this allows us not only to control
the
culturing condition but also to make
sure that they are
always optimal
so which cellular features should a good
media support
here you may see some data obtained from
psc lines
grown in stem max ips brew xf
so first of all a good media allows pse
to maintain their
typical morphology
second a robust media must support
and allow the continuous and stable
expression of pluripotency associated
markers
during the culture by doing so
it also allows the preservation of the
cells in a pluripotent state and does
not induce a bias
in the differentiation capabilities of
our line
as just mentioned psc culture have
actually distinct metabolic demands
and do not tolerate very well stress
conditions
and this is the reason why media changes
have
been traditionally performed with
24-hour interval
but some robust and optimized cultural
media
have the additional advantage of
allowing
a more flexible feeding schedule
so for example here you may see some
different
feeding strategies that can be adopted
when using stem max ips brew
so we can have a classical everyday
feeding
or we can have every other day
feeding or finally we can have a
so-called weekend-free feeding so
no feeding for to consecutive days
after some days in culture
psc will reach confluence and they will
need to be splitted
in additional culture plates and as you
might
already know splitting the psc culture
is a delicate
time point and of course specific
techniques
and reagents are necessary so that we
can maintain
a stable line in general
it's important to keep in mind that
different
lines have also different growth
kinetics
and therefore the splitting should
always be
assessed by having a look at the cells
under a microscope
generally uh we can say that it's a good
practice to keep
culture in a in a subconfluent stage
where we can still see the colonies
being separated among each other clearly
classical splitting techniques so for
example by
trypsin edition do not work
very well with pscs because the
detachment must be
really gentle so that we can maintain
maximum viability
and we can avoid spontaneous
differentiation
there are different methods to passage
psc culture
so the cotton paste method consists in
dividing the
psc colony with a needle under a
microscope
and actually this method takes
kind of a long time and it can be used
just if you are working with a low
number of culture
therefore we generally do not recommend
it
the other two methods are actually more
suited when
working with more than one line at the
time
and they are generally weaker
so for example splitting the culture by
single cell passaging
so by creating a cell suspension
is advisable when we need to perform a
cell counting before sitting
or we need to analyze the cells
these are the cases because this is a
relatively more hard method and
therefore
is not really well suited for routine
passaging
for routine passaging we advise in fact
to use
reagents that allow for the so-called
cluster passaging with this method
uh pscs are detached from the culture
metrics
as small aggregates and those this
allows
the preservation of cell to cell
contacts that are
pivotal in the maintenance of a
pluripotent phenotype
how does it work so here you can see a
time course detachment of psc colonies
done using the stamax passaging solution
as you can see after adding the solution
the cells will start to progressively
lift from the matrix
after about five minutes clusters can be
completely detached from the metrics by
just by pipetting up and down and
if needed the aggregates can be reduced
in smaller pieces by keeping on
pipetting up and down finally
the cell cluster can be transferred
and seeded into new cultureware
so during culture
batches of cells should always be frozen
in order to have always some cellular
backups
cryopreservation is not only important
as a good laboratory practice
but also for the creation of large
repositories
and by banks here you can see some
advices
so always freeze back up batches of
cells at an
early passage of course you should
always freeze just good quality cells
and finally the more defined the
freezing solution
is the more consistent your towing
efficiency will be
when using a defined freezing solution
in fact
we can expect consistent performances of
the psc
culture after towing
here you may see an assessment of cell
recovery
and viability of psc lines that were
originally frozen in stem max cryoboo
freezing solution and thought in stem
max ips broom
after throwing you can see that the
cells
show a high and reproducible recovery
rate
as well as viability and they do not
have a drastic alteration
in the doubling time additionally
you can see here below that the psc
lines
retain all their typical characteristics
so we quickly mentioned that psc
must show some specific characteristic
let's now look in more in detail what
these
are and what we mean by the term
psc characterization
so pse characterization includes
all the assays that are usually
performed
in order to confirm the pluripotency the
quality
the identity and the safety of a
pluripotent cell
line and this is a critical point
and the comprehensive characterization
is
mandatory when establishing new lines
and also as a good practice
during propagation of already
established line
so during psc characterization we
actually want to assess
first if the line has a typical
morphology
then if the expression of markers
is consistent with the pluripotent state
third if the line can differentiate into
cells that's derived from the three
embryonic lineages
and finally if the line has a normal
karyotype
when the line passes all these tests
then
it can be considered to be a high
quality psc line
so let's start with the first and
actually the
easiest feature to assess so the
cell and colony morphology being
a pst extremely sensitive cells
one of the first events that happens
when a line
loses its its characteristic is the
change in morphology
an optimal psc line should in fact
grow as a homogeneous and monolayer
culture
whereas the cell itself presents a scar
cytoplasm and it grows tightly packed
with other cells
forming colonies that are characterized
by having
sharp and defined borders here on the
right
you may see an example of pse morphology
and we strongly advise to monitor
the cellular morphology as often
as possible
in fact if the cells are
cultured under suboptimal condition
or they are exposed to environmental
stress
or if the line is just not a good
quality one
the psc may go an unwanted
spontaneous differentiation and here you
can see
the most common signs of alteration in
psc morphology
so starting from the left you may see an
example of
flat outgrowing of big cells
then an example of a colony that has
not really well-defined borders and
finally an example of central
differentiation
and loss of of the monolayer growth
so what should we do uh if we see
uh one of these cases in our culture
well the best solution would be of
course to
throw a batch of the same line that was
frozen
at the earlier passage unfortunately
we know all that this is not always
possible
and therefore an alternative approach
can be
to perform a positive selection of
pscs by pancreatic isolation
in fact the plcs that are still
expressing stem cell specific markers
can be isolated with a magnetic
separation
so the cells are harvested and
we are going to generate a single cell
suspension
then the cells are magnetically labeled
and in this case the labeling is for a
specific pac marker
trau 160 and allows us to target
just the cells that we want to to
maintain
these cells are going to be retained in
the magnetic fields
and after that they can be
eluted from the column then plated and
then we can start our culture again
as you can see from the plot
on the upper part of this slide
in this way we can efficiently and
quickly remove
differentiated cells so that we can
generate a pure
and homogeneous population of pscs for
subsequent culture or for
differentiation
second characteristic that psc needs to
show
is a stable and high expression of
intracellular and surface markers
that are well known to be associated
with a pluripotent phenotype
the expression can be monitored either
by
immunofluorescence or by flow cytometry
we generally advise for flows and flow
cytometry
uh since this allows not only
a qualitative assessment but also
quantitative evaluation of your
culture here you may see an example of
the assessment of pluripotency marker
expression
in one ipfc line
with our multi-color panel for flow
cytometry
so the antibody panel described here
enables the detection of both surface
and intracellular markers the percentage
of
of the marker expression is then plotted
in the matrix below and can help us
to quickly assess the phenotype of the
line
so as you can see the line on the left
shows high expression
marking red of pluripotency markers
such as ca4 160 sox2 octrim
whereas it shows a low expression of a
differentiation marker
in green and marker is cd15
conversely on the right panel we can see
the expression profile of this
of differentiated cell line
let's now move to the assessment of
pluripotency
so pfc by definition need to be
able to differentiate into cellular
types that derive from the three
embryonic germ layers so another
mesoderm and ectoderm
this property can be assessed in various
way
both in vitro and in vivo
classically pluripotency has been tested
in vivo
using the teratoma assay teratomas
are a distinct type of tumors that are
made up
from several different types of tissue
uh in the assay putative pluripotent
stem cells are
implanted into a immune compromised
mouse
where they will proliferate and
differentiate to form a teratoma
just in the case they are pluripotent
nevertheless this method is of course
long
and certainly requires ethical approval
and it's not really well suited for
assessment
in a routine way of your of your
cultures
in these cases the in vitro approach
is to be preferred we have two
assays that are currently being used
one is the embryo body formation assay
and the other one is the trillionaire
differentiation assay
to the embryo body assay
is based on the fact that high quality
pscs
when grown as a three-dimensional
aggregate
in the absence of a patterning factor
will spontaneously differentiate in
cellular types that derive from the
three embryonic germ layers
these spherical aggregates actually
slightly resemble
an embryo and that's the reason why they
are called them bright bodies
the embryo bodies are usually in italy
grown in suspension for about two weeks
and then they are plated for about one
week
in the first phases cells are
maintained in a culture in media that
it's not supplemented with cytokines or
small molecules
but is formulated so that the cell
survival
and the multiplication can can be
supported
so for example by stem max div base xf
the final analysis of the expression of
the various markers
can be done either by flow cytometry or
by
immunofluorescence
an alternative in the through test that
can be used to
quickly assess the pluripotency of a psc
line
is the trilineage differentiation assay
so this test is is based on the use of
cytokine containing a media
that allow the directed differentiation
into ectodermal mesodermal or endodermal
lineages
so if a line is a true psc line
it will be able to differentiate
here you may see a really schematic
protocol
for the standmax3 lineage
differentiation kit
so basically one psc clone is plated
into three separate walls
and each one of them will be fed with a
specific media from the kit
consistent with one of the three germ
layers
already at day seven as you can see the
cells are ready to be analyzed
also in this case we can
analyze the assay by classical
immunogenochemistry
or with flow cytometry
here as an example you can see the
assessment
that was performed with our affinity
recombinant
antibody panel the panel consists of
two marker combination for each germ
layer
and includes both surface and
intracellular markers
this is not only a fast readout of the
pluripotent potential of allow
of a line but it also allows us to
better understand
if our lines are biased towards the
differentiation
into one specific lineage
okay so now that we saw how to maintain
high quality pscs
we can actually move to the core aspect
of psc research so differentiation
so plc differentiation is achieved
by the sequential addition of patterning
factors
so cytokines small molecules and so on
in a media formulated for the metabolic
requirements
of that specific cell type the
key factors during psc differentiation
are the combination of back turning
factors
that we add their concentration and of
course
the timing
by changing these this criteria
over the last years many different
protocols have been published
to differentiate different cell types
but also to differentiate the same cell
type
although of course this was aimed to
establish an optimal reference protocol
this large amount of different
possibilities
creates problems in terms of
experimental reproducibility
in in fact the phenotype of the cells
that we can obtain with the different
protocols
might not always be completely
comparable so for example
they might be in in different maturation
stages
and also the rate ratio
between cells that were successfully
differentiated
and cells not differentiated may vary
and this leads to a heterogeneous
population that are actually
difficult to quantify so
other than being a confounding
factor for for the experimental output
the percentage among this possible
population
can also additionally vary uh in each
round of differentiation
and this results in a poor experiment to
experiment consistency
therefore there is an underlying needs
of solution to improve the
differentiation
and increase the standard dispensation
of
of our psc differentiation
how can we increase the standardization
of differentiation
well the first advice is to
opt for ready to use media kit
for the differentiation if they are
available
this of course reduces operator errors
eliminates inconsistencies that are
due to a lot too lot variation of the
of the reagents and of the components
and
in general is the um the the creation of
the experimental model
so that we can have more time to to
focus on the
actual experimental application and not
just in
generating our cellular model
so here is an example of a xeno-free
and ready-to-use media kit for the
differentiation of pse
derived the cardiomyocytes the stem max
cardiodis kit excess
in this case no supplemental additional
factors
is required and the differentiation is
achieved by just mixing the appropriate
media
and feeding it to the cells
differentiation with the stem max
cardiodysket excess
takes place just in eight days so first
the stem cells are seeded as single
cells
in mesoderm induction medium then the
cardiac state is induced on day two
and beating cardiomyocytes can already
be observed
by day six and of course depending on
the line
the differentiated cardiomyocytes can be
cultured further if they are fed every
second day with the stomach's cardiac
cultivation medium
after differentiation cells
show expression of several cardiomyocyte
specific markers such as for example
cardiac t
troponin as assessed by flow cytometry
here
and also by immunofluorescence staining
the use of the mediakits leads to high
efficiency
and more importantly high experiments to
experiment consistency as you can
see here shown by the graph where
where the percentage of cells positive
for cardiac troponin tin
in different line and the experiment has
been plotted
but what to do in the case we are
still optimizing a differentiation
protocol
or we cannot use a ready-to-use media
kit
well we can still limit viability
and increase standardization and
consistency
by for example using a ready-made
xeno-free blank medium as base media for
the differentiation
additionally we of course should use
high quality
cytokines and small molecules
keeping always in mind to check for
their
biological activity finally we can use
isolation strategies to ensure
to have a homogeneous population of
differentiated cells
in in the next slides we will present
each of these
topics in detail
so ready to use base media
with this term we refer to a medium that
does not
yet contain cytokines or small molecules
for the differentiation
but it has a complex composition
that helps for cell survival and
proliferation
the the bayes media is then supplemented
with
different combination of cytokines and
small molecules
according of course to the
differentiation
pathway that we chose here you may see
the results of early differentiation
that was obtained by combining different
patterning factors
with standards max disbase itself as you
can see
this base medium can be used directly
without the need of cell adaptation
and supports direct differentiation both
in protocols with adherent culture
and in protocols that pass by a
eb stage
so how can we be sure to
use always the same amount of active
cytokine
in every differentiation round well
we always should assess the biological
activity
so that this can be maintained constant
among the experiment this is because
the cytokine specific biological
activity
can depend on the vendor and pro on the
production lot
this variation of course can lead to a
differentiation where
the culture is either over or under
saturated and of course the good
researchers should
assess every time that the cytokine
activity
is is the same or it should use
cytokines where the activity
values have already been measured so for
example
with the max premium grade cytokines
let's now come to the last point to
increase standardization that is cell
isolation
so as you know pst differentiation often
leads to a heterogeneous mixture of
cells
part of them are correctly
differentiated and
part of them have just a typical
phenotype
having a homogeneous population is of
course extremely
important so that we can have a reliable
results in our experiments and
of course measure the response just from
the correct
target cells enriching
the target cell population we can
control the percentage of pfc derived
cells
so that is consistent among various
experiments
why is this important well let's see
this example
on hepatocytes differentiation
so the cellular types descending from
the
endodermal lineage will pass through an
intermediate state that is known as
that is known as definitive endoderm
this initial patterning can be done in
vitro
by the addition of specific cytokine
such as for example active in
a then the sequential addition of other
cytokines and small molecules
will allow us for the terminal
differentiation
during the differentiation uh we
evaluated the
percentage of cells that were expressing
um definitive endotherm markers such as
fox a2 sox17 and
cxcr and what we saw
was that already at this
intermediate stage the cells actually
resemble
a heterogeneous population
as you can see from the flow datum
in fact just about a half of the cells
in population does not express
definitive endoderm
markers it's it's kind of clear that
this
will of course further reduce the
success
of our downstream differentiation into
for example hepatic cells
therefore we modified the original
protocol
by including an isolation step for the
definitive endoderm
by using the cd 184 micro bit kit
let's see how this has an impact on the
final population
so by comparing the expression of
hepatocytes markers
in cells obtain without
and with isolation step it's
clear that the letter shows a higher
expression of hypothesized marker
importantly of course the same isolation
strategy
can be used also for the other cell
types that
derive from the definitive endoderm
so we are now at the end of this webinar
and we saw how pluripotent stem cells
are
very sensitive cells and appropriate
cycle regions
and handling are of course key factors
in maintaining
your cells at their best moreover
we highlighted how psc characterization
should always be performed both after
reprogramming
but also as routine practice in
maintenance culture
finally we showed several different
strategies
that can be used to increase the
standardization during
psc differentiation
and with this i would like to thank you
all for your
attention
thank you viola for your informative
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
okay let's go ahead and get started our
first question
is in which case would you recommend
performing the trillionaire
differentiation assay
rather than the embryoid body's assay
yeah so well as i mentioned
of course both the tests are extremely
valuable and efficient to assess the
differentiation potential of a line
but that being said um it's clear that
that
lineage differentiation assay is is a
faster
alternative to the bright body assay
since it requires just seven days
compared to yeah about three weeks
and additionally also on a handling
point of view
the three lineage is way easier to
perform because you just have to
feed the cells with pre-made media so
i would personally uh suggest to
use the three lineage as say um as a
solution when we want to
do our routine assessment and we maybe
uh are assessing uh different
yeah many lines at the same time whereas
i would suggest to use the embryoid body
assay
just seldomly and just in the case we
are assessing just a
low number of lines so for example
when we are doing the first steps after
establishment of a new ipsc line so
after reprogramming
okay your next question what would you
suggest to do in case a psc line
fails a characterization assay
yeah yeah of course that unfortunately
this can happen
so uh clearly uh the first thing i
i would suggest to do is of course to
repeat the test
uh if we see that the line uh still
fails
the test and additionally for example is
starting to present
morphological alteration and yeah this
additional feature
then uh we can be pretty sure that the
line is no longer
a high quality line but before
doing any other action i would suggest
to
try to pinpoint what was the cause of it
so we should ask ourselves is this loss
of pluripotent characteristic
due to the fact that the line somehow
was not
intrinsically genetically stable or
was it due to to the fact that maybe
it went um under some stressful
cultural condition so for example was it
split
correctly was it fed with an appropriate
schedule
was the media correctly prepared and so
on
once we have identified what was the
variable
in the culturing that changed then we
can proceed
to so a new clone that um of course
will proliferate better because we will
correct
this this failure that we had before
okay we'll move on to your next question
while assessing the expression of
pluripotency associated markers
how many should we check okay
so um in general the rule of thumb here
is
the more markers you assess the best it
is
anyway in any case we always want to
make sure
that we assess for a combination of both
intracellular and surface markers that
of course
are well known to be associated with uh
with our pluripotent phenotype
as a as a minimum criterium i would
suggest at least two of each
type and um additionally i think
it's it's always nice to add to the
assessment also
a marker for early differentiation so
for example we could add
cd15 to our assessment
thank you looks like we have time for
one more question
so for which cell types would you
suggest
performing an isolation step at a
progenitor stage
rather than on the differential cell
type
okay so well generally speaking um
the isolation can be performed at any
stage
but of course for some cell types and
for some protocols
one time point may be better than the
other
and these really depends on what cell
type we are differentiating
so we generally perform an isolation
step
at a progenitor stage when first of all
there is a defined progenitor stage and
when
this progenitor has a well-defined
phenotype
so so that we can have a specific marker
to level for for the separation
alternately we can also perform the
isolation and
final maturation stage
but this is advisable just when we are
working with a robust
and well-defined cell type so one
example
can be the psc derived cardiomyocyte
so yeah in general there are a lot of
possibilities that
mostly depends on what cell you are
differentiating
thank you again viola do you have any
final comments for our audience before
we go today
uh yeah of course i would like to thank
you all
again for the attention and then i would
like to thank
la brut for making this uh webinar
possible
well thank you so much for your time
today and your important research
research we would also like to thank
labrutz and our sponsor miltoni biotech
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labors will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye